seeing the other thing about marriage
this is really worth knowing too is that
I've learned this in part from reading
Young's like what do you do when you get
married that's easy you take someone
who's just as useless and horrible as
you are and then you shackle yourself to
them and then you say we're not running
away no matter what happens yeah well
that that's perfect because then you
don't get to run away and the thing is
is like if you can run away you can't
tell each other the truth because if you
tell someone the truth about you and
they don't run away they weren't
listening and so if you don't have
someone around to count run away then
you can't tell them the truth and so
that's part of the purpose of the
marriage it's like okay okay I'll bet on
you you bet on me too losing bet we both
know that but given our current
circumstances were unlikely to find
anyone better that's for sure you know
there's two things would come off of
that one is you know people are waiting
around to find mr. or mrs. right it's
like here's something to think about man
to put yourself on your feet right if
you went to a party and you found mr.
right and he looked at you and didn't
run away screaming
that would indicate that he wasn't mr.
right at all right it's like the old
Nietzsche and joke if someone loves you
that should immediately disenchant you
with them right right or it's the Woody
Allen joke I never belong to a club that
would take me as a member so so that's a
that's an interesting that's a very
interesting thing to think about and so
you're going to shackle yourself to
someone who's just as a as imperfect as
you are and then the issue is you you
you might be in a situation where you
can actually negotiate because you might
think well there's some things about you
that aren't going so right and there's
some things about me that aren't going
so right and we're bloody well stuck
with the consequences for the next 50
years so we could we can either
straighten this out or we can suffer
through it for the next five decades and
you know people are of the sort that
without that degree of seriousness those
problems will not be solved you'll leave
things unnamed because there's always an
else like and it's the same thing when
you're living together with someone you
know that people who live together
before they're married are more likely
to get divorced not less likely and the
for that is what exactly are you saying
to one another when you live with each
other just think about it well for now
you're better than anything else I can
trick but I'd like to reserve the right
to trade you in conveniently if someone
bitter happens to stumble into me well
how could how could someone not be
insulted to their core by an offer like
that now they're willing to play along
with it because they're going to do the
same thing with you
now well that's exactly it it's like
yeah yeah I know you're not going to
commit to me so that means you don't
value me or our relationship above
everything else but as long as I get to
escape if I need to then I'm willing to
put up with that it's like that's a hell
of a say I mean you might think how
stupid is it to shackle yourself to
someone it's like it's stupid man
there's no doubt about that
but compared to the alternatives it's
pretty damn good because without that
shackling there are things you will
never ever learn because you'll avoid
them you can always leave and if you can
leave then you don't have to tell each
other the truth it's as simple as that
because you can just leave and then you
don't have anyone you can tell the truth
to
[Applause]